okay I hope you all had a wonderful and
epic 2019 that time has come the time
for me to give you my list of the top
ten best movies of 2019 per my opinion
and the movies that I actually saw
that's a couple things to keep in mind
there actually there's a couple things
to keep in mind every year I do this one
I have not seen every movie that came
out in 2019 that's the constant every
year just I don't see every movie just
the way it is about Christmas time if I
haven't seen it yet
I'm not going to I've been me long
enough to know that that's just how that
is also these are not the top ten
technically perfect films of 2019
my favorites these aren't reviews I'm
gonna say a couple things about the
movie I list and move on to the next one
if you want reviews I have reviews of
all the movies on this list on my
channel go check them out have fun and
funny enough just because I gave a movie
in awesome tacular does not guarantee it
passage into the list of the top 10 best
movies of the year for me it's actually
one movie I can think of in particular
didn't make it on but I'm very happy
with this list not gonna bore you too
much with this intro any longer because
that's the boring part so here's my
unprofessional very biased and
subjective list of my top 10 favorite
movies of 2019 starting with number 10
starting at this list at number 10 uncut
gems funny enough it's the movie I saw
most recently I only saw this movie a
couple days ago I haven't had a lot of
time to marinate on it however one
thing's for sure
I saw something special here I don't
know if it's due to the fact that I was
surprised because I was blindsided in
the best way possible the fact that Adam
Sandler was great but it's a quick
moving very fast paced anxiety-filled
look into this hustlers life this
hustler that you really do empathize
with I thought it was great check it out
9 next up dark waters dark waters is one
of those movies when I was going into it
I was like okay this is what I expect a
slow-moving well acted drama that's
hopefully interesting it's a while like
the drama that is interesting but it
didn't move as slowly as I thought it
was going to this movie actually really
hooked me I was invested I was there a
corporate cover up from the highest
level no regard for human life you know
unpacking that Pandora's box and it
shines a light on something where you're
like are we gonna resolve that it hasn't
been resolved my mom got pans for
Christmas this year I was like is it
Teflon is fascinating next up is the
Irishman look I'm a sucker for Martin
Scorsese mob epics that's what he
delivered with the Irishman the likes of
which I felt I hadn't gotten from him in
many years he's taking us back to his
casino vibe his Goodfellas vibe I didn't
feel it was as good
those two other movies but he delivered
it's a movie that goes for the angle to
make the audience contemplate their own
mortality if you didn't stick that
landing that movie with a foam fly but
he did stick that landing and good for
him
next up ya Shazam okay I figured Shazam
is gonna squeak into my top 10 and it
did but then among all the movies my
family and I could have watched at
Christmas any of the Christmas classics
Christmas Story
Christmas vacation die hard we watched
Shazam for some weird reason and that
bump Shazam up a couple notches on my
list in a world where we are inundated
with superhero movies Shazam is
something that it just it's refreshing
it's refreshing it's also one of the
better comedies of 2019 because it's
actually hilarious but the comedies not
out of place because the subject matter
completely lends itself to comedy and
when the movie cranks up the sentimental
notches on the family dynamic yeah I get
the feels it's a good one Shazam is
great six we're gonna stick into the
superhero genre for a second because
Avengers endgame that also happened you
can say Avengers infinity war is the
climax this is the tribute but it's the
conclusion of finale of an active 10
year arc Avengers endgame has some great
character moments some great tribute
moments some great fanservice moments
and some great send-off and among all of
that they still stuck the landing for
the finale of their Avengers saga I
appreciate a movie that can do all of
that there was a time in my life I knew
I didn't think I knew I would never see
anything like Avengers end game on
screen yet here we are in it it just
turns me into a kid every time five
alright so now we're getting into those
surprises those movies that weren't even
on my radar and then I'm like wait a
minute you mean ready or not is great
like one of my favorites of the year
great yep and it's here here at number
five the movie is fun it's violent it's
ridiculous it's slick it's cool this is
such an absurd premise that is pulled
off brilliantly crazy family or people
hunting someone down yeah that happens
in movies but the way it's delivered in
this one that's the unique element this
is a devilishly good time I'm interested
to see how many top-ten lists ready or
not is actually on I don't know I don't
know the answer it remains one of my
favorites of the year obviously one
could argue the fifth favorite keeping
with those surprises fighting with my
family room
one of the more enjoyable wholesome
times I've had at the movies this year
true story of WWE Superstar Paige but
like any great film you don't have to be
a fan of the subject matter you know the
career they have in order to connect
with the characters that's what this
movie does this is written and directed
by Stephen Merchant I can't wait to
watch more movies of his because he
completely crushed it not only is it
heartfelt it's hilarious it's I feel
like I'm talking about Shazam it's all
the same words really I'm a sucker for a
good strong enjoyable family dynamic
what can I say I'm a SAP but fighting
with my family you will have a smile on
your face
do yourself a favor check it out next up
Ford vs. Ferrari this is another movie
if you're like I'm not a car person
doesn't matter
first of all Matt Damon and Christian
Bale crush it in this one Christian Bale
cannot get overlooked here but it's
about the creative spirit the
entrepreneurial spirit and the fact that
the company even if it's the one you
work for they're just gonna metal and
make things difficult because they're
not artists even by the end of it you're
like did that really have you look into
what you're like yeah totally did this
was actually my number two of the year
until nineteen seventeen happened and in
nineteen seventeen became number two of
the year nineteen seventeen is the
definition of epic a simple story of a
couple of relatable nobody soldiers in
World War one have to go on their
journey and relate orders to their
troops deep in enemy territory also all
film to look like it's all one shot I've
seen the one shot movie done before and
it is undeniably very immersive
logically the next step would be well
let's bring it to a war film that should
be immersive an epic right yes this
movie was intense when bullets weren't
even flying when he's just creeping
through dark places hoping there's not
an enemy around him it's more intense
because you're there you're hoping an
enemy's not around you because for all
intents and purposes you are in World
War one with these guys it's a wide
release in January I'm gonna be singing
his praises until it comes out and I'm
gonna be singing his praises more number
one on the list my boy Joker Joker isn't
was amazing it started controversy that
it had nothing to do with really aside
from that longtime subscribers as you
know I'm a huge Joker fanatic
rather than the unstoppable force the
hurricane of Gotham he's this sad story
of this person getting beaten down in
life they took the concept of of someone
breaking in one bad day just made it one
bad life and to be honest with you it
was everything I wanted in a standalone
Joker movie we can't have it here and
not talk about Joaquin Phoenix
he was truly amazing I hope he gets
nominated for an Oscar for this like I
feel like the only thing that would keep
that from happening is the Academy's
like but we nominated another Joker are
we really gonna do that twice yes you
completely should do it twice I've seen
Joker backstories before in the comic
books actually Jack Nicholson Joker he
had a backstory and I always find them
interesting but this one I actually
empathize with him I felt bad for the
guy I felt bad for the Joker I know what
the Joker ends up being I know the
monster he is and I felt bad for him
this movie's epic I enjoyed the
conversations that were happening on
YouTube about Joker like the what did
this mean what did that mean was there
symbolism here was it all in his head I
actually made a video myself more than
that I was just so glad they pulled it
off and Joker is my favorite movie of
2019 all right so that's it those are my
top 10 favorite movies of 2019
Wow I feel like I sped through that
faster than normal hey what can I say no
sense of drawing it out if you want to
hear me elaborate a little more on how I
felt about the movies I'll put links
below to the video reviews just number
them 1 through 10 without the titles no
cheating I mean at this point in the
video you already know but still but I
sincerely want to thank you all for
sticking around for another year with me
putting up with me that jump cut [ __ ]
with his red background how dare he
talking about movies and such I mean
I'll spare you from me getting too sappy
but you know I've always been a person
who likes talking movies so thank you
for being like I like that casual guile
stick around I appreciate you all I just
want you to know I don't take any of you
for granted it's because of you I get to
do what I do I really I take that to
heart
alright I got to take off because I'm
starting to lose my voice I gotta save
my voice box for the top 10 worst movies
of the year 2019 yeah that videos coming
so what's your list what are your top 10
favorite movies of 2019 whatever they
are comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you
[Music]